I knew it was you Anna Craig Lamar and
we're gonna do the baby food challenge
you guys have been requesting this seem
a little these comments here it's a lot
of comments oh they'll be there so we to
be blind board and we're going to feed
each other baby food and we have to
guess what it is and the good news is we
have a blindfold Erbil so you bucket and
we have this what is this it's a dog
that's you ladybug Lamarr they call if
someone's gonna burp me yes who wants to
go first
I'll go first okay great Wow oh it works
it works honey would you turn crows good
good get hungry
oh my baby sausage is it a meat flavor
yes okay
beef chicken noodle oh yes I do it
tasted like chef boyardee ravioli
I won't look for defeating this one
where it is terrible yes actually
[Music]
oh gosh don't worry your best okay
yummy yummy go is it cranberry yes it's
okay yes the maximum everybody now I'm
allergic to nuts there's not a nut
flavoured ones yeah okay well you just
want us that everything so no I mean
like how allergic to nuts are you really
not not peanuts but all other nuts
you'll feel like you'll have to go to
the mortuary
[Music]
can I keep this like this you meant oh
okay
you own Divya this a little bit crank
that one
oh god that smells gross oh I hate you
more
no Peas let's split this is split pea
yeah
are you drunk there's not even a single
vegetable witness what you're actually
chasing is chicken and gravy chicken and
gravy I should know chicken it smells
terrible
yeah it's I don't have babies were like
chicken after this yeah yeah let's work
liquid is for it that's lover oh yeah I
bought it myself
yes I did big spoonful I'll taste this
Turkey something right
no it's a familiar taste though yes
would you want to out anything I can't
think of a fruit there like dates
how about carrots which is not very
Sheriff oh that was carried yeah I read
carriages doesn't taste like here it's
for baby sling their birds not me Gerber
what you do of it but if you look at the
ingredients it looks like they they use
more real food and these than we yeah
that's true though
stunwin okay
mix it up a little chicken and gravy hey
[Music]
that's a good Lamar that's a good Lamar
oh that one of us discuss the weeds man
it tastes like puke
really yes it looks like you I mean it
literally it tastes like the stomach
thing comes up it's just it's bro what
is that Peas exactly yeah all right your
turn why not because I already have it
in my eyes okay oh that's a new one
wait ooh I don't like to smell it
smell like Lamar
oh all right here goes so much oh thank
you so much
not so much we're giving you oh oh dear
oh it's definitely the chicken freakin
noodle no no no don't you dare open my
house oh it's so great a one more guess
around so grainy poison don't make sure
you didn't grab the poison I like this
one actually yes a Morgan okay okay but
that's probably pretty good okay ready
uh-huh alive yeah no you gotta get up
you gotta get sloshed chicken gravy
[Music]
sweet potatoes potatoes squash with
folks yeah that was really good this one
right here don't know what you got open
there it is this one's out that
shouldn't be oh it's so delicious
really good that was three right yeah
yeah let's do it
is that the last time we're so good yeah
you ready ready okay no you guys eat the
chicken sticks no I don't know I swear
to you I'm not even joking there's only
good okay I'll try one it was in there
good I said we're actually good yes this
looks good
I'm willing if I win I'm not put the
whole thing in them no I'm only bite
then so okay ready one two three
I'm good is it not bad it's not bad
you're over-exaggerating this is
delicious
I'm not always a great it is your what
you're enjoying it I don't like the
consistency the efficacy is throw me off
pretty gross it tastes good thank you
all I know is the woman that check outs
like oh my gosh how old is your child
you know I'm gonna have my two I'm gonna
have some more friends I'm gonna have so
much this I want to try this banana I
want to try that banana this that
everyone's done anything about okay
there we go
honestly really good all right what is
it like my juggling juice yeah yeah it
isn't that bad sir it's good there's
like it tastes like a smoothie oh that's
good that's a banana smoothie right
there good blueberry Oh on this action
why do I have the pink spoon that feels
like an applesauce
it's good that one's pretty good it's
like watery apple sauce oh yeah that's
great thank you guys for watching your
baby food challenge
make sure you leave a copy laughs know
if you enjoyed it and check out their
YouTube channels they'll be linked here
below and these magic annotations what
kind of funny annotations what is your
favorite baby food
guess what we get a video with in a
video we did on my channel so check that
we didn't know anything at my channel
no that's sad
[Music]